alberto fernández se convirtió en el
primer presidente de latinoamericano en
recibir la vacuna contra el cobre 19 el
mandatario de 61 años fue inoculado con
la primera dosis luego de que el
regulador de salud de argentina aprobara
la vacuna de fabricación rusa para su
uso entre mayores de 60 años ya son más
de 265.000 dosis administradas hasta
ahora dando prioridad al personal de la
salud cuando nos enteramos que estaba la
primer dosis
a notar me vine me vacuné bien no tuve
ningún síntoma
y con la segunda dosis ayer estuvo en
contacto me avisaron vine y bueno nada
contenta porque
y está moviendo de que hay otra vez
rebrote y con la atención del paciente
uno está más tranquilo
al grupo de países que empezaron las
vacunaciones se suma ecuador méjico
costa rica brasil y chile
algunos médicos y enfermeras en egipto
fueron los primeros en recibir una de
las 8.000 dosis de la farmacéutica
pfiezer en mexico a pesar del rápido
inicio de la campaña hasta el momento se
han aplicado un poco más de 500.000
dosis es decir al 0 39 por ciento de su
población
'brasil con más de 213 millones de
habitantes apenas ha aplicados 136 mil
dosis en cambio en países como colombia
donde se vive a una segunda ola de la
pandemia de kobe 19 las vacunas
compradas a la farmacéutica pfiezer
llegarán hasta la primera semana de
febrero en nuestro país son más de 50
mil compatriotas que han fallecido
producto de esta enfermedad tan compleja
tan difícil y tan letal para muchos
sectores de la población muchos otros
países de la región como bolivia perú y
venezuela aún parecen estar lejos de
iniciar las vacunaciones contra el
coronavirus